monday marks the 50th anniversary of the
deadly shootings at Kent State
University in Ohio a key event during
the Vietnam War era four students were
killed and nine were wounded when
National Guard troops opened fire during
an anti-war protest well much has
changed in the five decades that have
passed for those who were there that day
the events of it remain fresh in their
minds worthy of reflection May 4 1970 I
had an English class that I went to and
it was kind of surreal because there was
just heavy military presence on campus
nearly a thousand Ohio National
Guardsmen were on the Kent State
University campus where John Cleary was
nearing the end of his freshman year the
guardsmen were called in after a mass of
protesters vandalized downtown buildings
and set fire to the university's ROTC
building there was just a lot of people
like me they were going to class I'm
just curious as to what was going on and
there was probably in the thousands
people just deserve
about 3,000 students had gathered on the
Commons not all but many were there to
rally against the invasion of Cambodia
even though the protest had been banned
some chanted or threw rocks when ordered
to disperse when tear gas was
ineffective the guard advanced forcing
demonstrators to retreat they did not
fire they got out and they began to
march back up the hill and just before I
was gonna go into Taylor Hall to get
ready for my classes I decided I'm gonna
get one more picture then just as he
reached across the hill they just
suddenly turned and fired a naive and
not realizing the danger I was and I
didn't dump her and got hit in the chest
with a bullet and it just knocked me
down
a student photographer captured that
moment which later captured the
attention of the nation when you see the
photos that actually convinced people of
the shooting it wasn't done by
professionals it was done all by
students John Philo is the vice
president of photography at Viacom CBS
on May 4th 1970 he was a Kent State
senior also shooting pictures Philo
wanted to document the essence of the
student protests but instead found
himself in the line of fire by the time
I got the camera back around to my eye
it was over the shooting was over I
never hit the ground and never just
stood there like an flat-footed idiot in
shock in shock yeah looking and then you
see this body behind you down on the
pavement and it's the blood is the
volume of blood is enormous it was
something Philo knew had to be seen to
be believed
so we took pictures and then could see
in the one frame the girls running up
and then she kneels down beside the body
and I said I gotta get her I gotta get
him it was almost in profile let me get
it more head-on and then she just let
out with a scream and you shot this
photograph of Mary Vecchio kneeling over
Geoffrey Miller one of four students
killed that day
would win Philo a Pulitzer Prize what
did you think when you saw the image
that we know because no I knew I
actually took the picture it wasn't just
in your mind that I took the picture I
had that moment of doubt because it was
such a shocking the adrenaline rush of
being shot at and surviving Philo's
picture would also inspire a protesting
Ohio performed by crosby Stills Nash and
young
[Music]
after the Kent State shootings more than
four million students protested across
the United States
I think it's remembered in large part
because so many students felt that it
could have been them thomas grace was
one of nine wounded that day i was hit
in the left heel and it just took the
right side of my left foot off now a
history professor grace wrote kent state
death and dissent in the long 60s which
looked at what happened and why he and
others maintained that an audio
recording reanalyzed in 2007 contains
evidence of an order to fire eight
guardsmen were indicted in 1973 for
their involvement but the case was
thrown out the following year grace is
among a group that believes the federal
investigation into the shootings should
be reopened even fifty years later so it
helps us to understand better what took
place there and that there was some
degree of foresight on the part of the
National Guard in terms of what they did
the National Guard always maintained
that they fired in defense of their
lives civil discourse and continued
dialogue surrounding the Kent State
shootings is in part what has motivated
the annual commemorations of that day
including this year's virtual ceremony
capping off a year-long observance of
the half-century gone by and while may
4th 1970 has personal meaning for those
who were there like John Cleary they are
the first to remind us it's a day we all
can and should learn from I know I've
had people and they said you mean there
were military on campus and they
actually shot people and they're what is
the danger of people not knowing what
happened that day the danger is that
it's forgotten
and that it could conceivably happen
again I think to remember and honor the
four students that were slain give some
weight and hopefully prohibits that kind
of action in the future
that commemoration is so important to
those who were there you have to
remember it took almost 20 years for the
university to actually acknowledge that
day they do have a beautiful memorial
that is there now and Jeff the words
that are on part of it enquire learn and
reflect again are so important to all
the men that we spoke with sounds like
good advice just horrifying still to see
those pictures and also to hear John so
vividly talk about what happened back
then Dana thank you very much details
you know